the first footage from the upcoming
Wonder Woman has been revealed it's
mostly Wonder Woman being very cute and
very serious I'm cake and this is your
gamespot news update as part of a DC
film special that ran on the CW a short
featurette was shown that includes cast
and crew interviews and a first look at
the movie Wonder Woman is still in
production and is being directed by
Patty Jenkins it's set for a June 2017
release and stars gala kado as the
amazonian princess turned superhero
alongside Chris Pine and Robin ripe
Godot will make her first appearance as
the character in batman vs. superman
dawn of justice which hits cinemas in
March director Zack Snyder recently
suggested that her role would be a
relatively important one he told film
Inc that it was bigger than a cameo
adding that she comes in and does
something I mean we basically already
seen most of it in the trailer thanks
for that Zack are we rapidly approaching
superhero saturation or is this your
idea of heaven let me know in the
comments or come and find me on Twitter
I met how not to draw thanks for
watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it games but